your
parents about what I you doing
prostitution I'm a legal escort in
Nevada sure okay that's what that means
that's you are a
prostitute doing things I'm not hurting
anybody people prostitute themselves for
a lot of other stuff besides sex you
know trust me I come out of the world of
politics like people sell out and do
anything for money and say what they
believe and then they act contrary so
like you know they would want me to do
what's best for me my parents want me to
do what whatever I'm happy with and
whatever I'm content with and that's
what love is you you could be happy and
content and independent without doing
sex work